okay
partnership
that's another common line modern day
dating partnership though question for
you do you want a man that's taller than
you
um idealistically speaking I do the
properly because I like to wear Hills I
like to be safe fantastic do you want to
gather stronger than you
yeah do you want a guy that makes more
money than you
yeah
oh [ __ ] hold on I gotta
um hold on I forgot
um
hold on let me refer to message
topic tonight
it art can relationships
really be 50 50. that'd be a good topic
what is a 50 50 relationship look
like that okay sorry guys you wanted to
make at least your equivalent if not
preferably better remember this is your
ideal guy yeah okay do you want a guy
that's more confident than yourself
yeah more experience than yourself yeah
okay you basically describe the superior
so you expect this guy to come in and
have a partnership with you whatever he
might Excel on I'll also add value in
other ways because it's not always about
being physically on the same on par with
that person just for certain
requirements like you can't buff a baby
you know yeah so we complement each
other in other ways and so we're still
equal in that sense men and women are
not equal at all
at all that's another fallacy that we
have in modern day dating culture which
leads so many women Australia we're not
the same there's certain things that men
can do that women can that can't do and
vice versa and we're different and we're
designed to complement each other and I
don't believe in Partnerships I think
men come in and Lead women follow
um and I agree with that
like
it's kind of weird because you don't
really think about it
um I don't know when your blue pill or
you're just like looking at the world
but the relationships that I admire the
most the woman follows the man and like
follows his lead and it doesn't really
seem to work when the woman leads
because she just kind of like busts his
balls all the time find it funny because
women typically want a man and here's
the thing what you just described is
what every girl wants but they think
that they're going to go into religion
with a guy that's better than them every
single metric and it's going to be an
equal partnership or 50 50. it doesn't
work that way there's always a leader
there's always a decider and for it to
work the man's got to be in leadership
role never the woman women can't lead
anything income it creates too much
pressure on you as a man then because if
you want to be this like Macho Man do
you not think that's going to cause a
lot of strain on a relationship pressure
creates diamonds
because here's the thing women are just
a cherry on top like you you should have
already he is right he's right look at
if if a woman's the Center of Your World
then you just ain't that guy that's what
I mean like
the guys that women want to be with
so you're just saying [ __ ] to them
because they're they have so many
so it's like like a woman shouldn't be
the center of a guy's world I agree by
the time she comes into the picture you
know you should have already conquered a
boardroom or conquered some kind of
physical labor played as Sports at some
point in your life uh endured some kind
of stress like men need to go through
pain men must become women are men must
become being a loser is unacceptable if
you're broke fat or you don't got
yourself together that's your problem
yeah but then that true true I agree
with that
I wonder if he says that
to the other way
Walter or whatever because then he
caught it chunky
like you would complain about women
because you'd say oh they only come for
like the glory of it like not the graph
so I'd rather be with someone that I'm
building with I've never I've never I've
never said that women build I actually
say the contrary I say women don't build
they move in yeah but and I acknowledge
that called reality 100 I tell guys they
need to build the castle so that she can
come in and you know you know what I
want to I'm gonna call a couple people
I'm gonna see
something
I just want to check something
I want to see if I'm going to call like
three of my female friends and ask them
what they'd prefer
a dad picks I'm gonna ask my dad
actually what's better
[Music]
I'll see I bet my dad will answer I let
my dad'll answer he wouldn't leave me on
he wouldn't not answer he wouldn't do
that to me
he wouldn't he wouldn't do that to me
he wouldn't
oh okay thank God quick question dad
um just you know I'm I'm on a stream
okay
okay I'm on a stream I'm on a stream I
just had a quick question
um so
if you if you had to pick okay so if I
had two guys trying to marry me they are
all the same okay but one was my age
he's 26 and he he was like working hard
and like building something and the
other one was 36 and he was already like
rich
which one would you say would be better
to pick
all things equal
they're never equal
um
because
one's a guarantee kind of one's not
so I would go with a 26 year old in my
case but in your case I'm not sure I
would
in your case I like hard work I think
the best thing
and so
but
my three it's a tiger Gap isn't huge
it's a big but not huge he said 20 years
I'd say no question 26 year old so if it
was if it was if it was if it was 46
you'd say to pick the 26 year old nine
question yeah not a question why would
you why would you say to pick the 26
year old
[Laughter]
oh no guarantees in life yeah you're
right but still it's still 20 years plus
you have much to comment people because
these are never equal the group are
different Generations like me dating a
three-year-old or something like that I
just different generation of people
oh it's a different generation I love
doing music instead of everything uh so
have you ever seen
a large age Gap work
have you ever seen a large age Gap work
like long term because you're old you've
actually seen people get together
um the answer question I mean
you know them they've seen they're like
20 years apart oh really
yeah and I think they've done pretty
well Sally and the the lady the lady in
Florida
the lady in Florida
okay I was just curious because they
were asking if women
um would rather like build with a guy or
they'd rather just like pick a guy
that's there and that's why I think he
had it has it already most women most
women would pick a guy that has it
already
oh God for sure why not why don't you
why are you at the building yet
why would you want to go I was gonna
take time that's right
there you have it my phone with it I
mean I'm gonna be sarcastic I don't
agree with it but I just don't know why
you wouldn't as a girl
do you think do you think do you think
my perspective is different because like
I grew up with money
already oh and you're building something
yeah
yeah
well that's I was just wondering because
I feel like money has
who's baby daddies
what is your group of people you deal
with all the time baby oh oh there yeah
what did they have that looks because if
they had money they'd probably still be
there oh that's a good question I could
ask on a show be like how much did your
baby daddy make
I don't think
I don't like the Ring of that
say yeah
you don't get as much to offer yeah so I
mean that I mean so
yeah like they're not because they're
good looking the part of the
conversation because I got money you're
thinking of money God
so
no I am so no that's that's the problem
it's a lot of questions there to answer
um okay
I was just wondering
okay good luck
okay thanks Dad love you bye
that's what my dad said what'd you guys
think
um
I want to see
um
is there any other girl I should call
that was kind of sad Everyone's Watching
Me be left let's see unseen
hmm
because I think I'd prefer to date
someone going there than there
but then people will be like cap cap cap
but I think that's only because like
there's a guarantee that he'd get there
in my head like see what I'm saying but
yeah okay things up here and there in
your Castle but at the end of the day
you got to build the structure women are
going to build it with you those days
are done women some women do though like
a lot of women do some no a few like the
ones I know I would say a minority a
majority want a guy that comes
pre-assembled yeah but why and can get
two different questions what what
percent got it got a chance with a guy
that's pre-assembled none is he talking
about
so we got to go off with the majority
knock on my North wait hold on actually
I have one other person that I'd like to
call
[Music]
um
so yeah let's go I'm advising men how to
you know operate in a dating Marketplace
I can't tell them look out for this 10
that wants to build with you no the
reality is most women want you to come
pre-assembled and to be honest the most
attractive and youngest women that have
the most options they definitely want
you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible